PEGI 18
in watch dogs too you are Marcus
Holloway a young brilliant hacker that
is part of a hacking group called dead
sec as you explore the Bay Area and help
dead sec Rowan power you're put in a
seamless connected world that offers
single and multiplayer opportunities
without lobbies or loading screens
as long as you're online there's always
a chance to meet other players follow
your way and keep playing solo or easily
form a co-op team and explore the world
together cruise around the bay and
discover new areas have a ride in the
back country and many other activities
through your smartphone take on an
endless series of co-op missions try to
get the best score and show who's the
best hacker in town holy [ __ ] this is
awesome
with online invasions fight off other
players trying to hack into your dead
sex systems use all your new hacking
tools to locate invaders and take them
down now it's your turn to seamlessly
invade other players session and hack
them while remaining undetected
if you create too much chaos such as
killing innocent civilians you could end
up with a bounty hunter contract on your
head this means up to three other
players can seamlessly invade your game
and hunt you down for a reward however
you can turn the tables and hunt down
those who are tracking you for even
bigger rewards everything you do online
and watch dogs too is optional but will
always contribute to your overall
progression in the game giving you
access to improved hacking tools and
gear
this is the online setting of watch dogs
too what do you do with it
you
for the players